Uh...
Hey, dudette.
Dude.
And dudettes.
Are you gonna, like, pick that up?
I think they're, like, really trying to get in contact with
you.
Are you, like...
Gonna pick that up?
Are you, like, gonna answer that?
Hey, dude.
Hey, dudette.
Um, actually...
It was me.
I'm the one calling you.
And you need to pick up your foe.
Because it's shredding time.
It's time to get groovy.
Welcome to not Metal Gear Solid 2.
Hey dude, how you doing that?
Do you know what day it is today?
Oh yeah.
Everybody salute.
Koshai!
Thanks for the 50 gift.
Thank you for the 50 gift.
Thank you!
It's April 30th, my dude!
It's April 30th!
The most important day!
Yeah!
On this day, my favorite couple in the world!
Shout-outs to you, Jack and Rose!
They've made...
And then they went home and watched King Kong.
And history was made!
So we're, like, gonna celebrate that.
Hey,
Min, did you know George Washington?
took office as the first president of the United States of
America over 200 years ago today today we're now the united
whispers of youtubers yeah let's see so if you were unaware
the um metal gear solid to uh substance has a special little
um extra thing we got going on here if you could see at the
very bottom Here's to you, best boy and worst girl.
She's not the worst girl, come on.
Snakeboarding, if you will.
Yes, snakeboarding.
So we'll be happy April 30th.
Happy April 30th.
Bluey ever.
So worst.
The Forgotten Sibling of the Emmerichs.
What's wrong with BB?
Skateboarding, that's a thing.
Oh yeah, it's only for...
It's only for MGS2 Substance.
So if you give it like the Master Collection or anything
like that, it's not going to be on there.
You got to get MGS2 Substance for the PS2.
2 baby I got my PS2 set up right over there I got my retro
tank 4k all hooked up I'm ready I'm so ready to skateboard
um honestly um I can't say how long today's stream is gonna
be because we could um I think there's like not that much to
do with this but um Yeah, I dropped some...
Okay, because I, like, was planning on doing a bunch of,
like, you know, PS2 games and stuff like that, I kind of
dropped the money on it.
So, it's for your viewing pleasure, everybody.
It's for your viewing pleasure.
You're welcome.
Oh, thank you for the Supertask, you guys!
I totally thought about doing, like, a marathon for this
stream.
you know playing up playing up to you know the game or like
playing marathoning the game or something but um honestly I
thought I kind of want to save MGS2 again for when I
properly replay the series so I didn't want to replay it and
have it on my channel and or play it have it on my channel
and then replay it again like sometime uh down the line I
don't know when so instead I was like can i do for april
30th and i was like oh wait a second i know the coolest
thing we could do dude
so without further ado oh sorry you'll see the everything
kind of loading feels so it feels so old School, right?
Oh my gosh.
Game, are you okay?
Oh, there we go.
Oh, yeah!
Raiden, to disarm the terrorists, you must shred on Arsenal
Gear.
Raiden, to save America, do An Olly, I don't know.
Welcome everybody to MGS2!
Let's see, controller.
We got Olly, small jump, hold the button to crouch and
release to jump.
That's the X button.
Simple enough, dude.
We got this dude.
We can grind, rail slide, jump on a rail, etc.
And hold down the triangle button to grind.
Oh yeah.
Riden, flips and grabs are done in mid-air.
A series of tricks can be done until you reach the ground.
Got it, dude.
We need those six flips, boss.
I got you.
Can't wait for Riden to activate roller blade mode.
Riden, do spins by turning while in mid-air.
Okay, L2 and R2 are spin.
Grab a circle, flip a square.
Um, I probably won't remember any of these.
Take a dup on your board.
Don't do that.
Don't dup on the board.
Duping is uncool.
On the board.
Oh, hiya.
Oh, hiya, gozaiima.
A dupe?
Nah, it's just Metal Gear Rising things, you know.
Riding gets it, riding gets it.
That was the audio, by the way.
Apparently there's a really cool remix of the song, so are
you shredding Mint?
Oh yeah!
Let's start.
Wait.
Oh my gosh, no way.
Hold on.
Let me go back real quick.
Ollie, grind, flip, and grab.
Flip and grab.
Flip, grab, flip, grab.
Grind, grind.
Ollie, Ollie, Ollie, Ollie.
Ollie, Ollie, up.
Time for a stream.
Also, I finally saved up the last $5 I own.
Oh, I own the Canadian Mafia stuff.
These DMV photos, they don't even look like them.
Like, what are these models?
They look so strange.
Who should we start as?
Should we start as Raiden because it's his big day?
Or should we start as Snake and finish with Raiden because
it's Raiden's big day, everybody?
No, that is not solid Snake.
Skateboard.
Snake first?
Alright.
Now loading.
Okay, here we go, baby.
All right, Ollie, grind.
Oh, I don't remember which one's flipping, which one's...
All right, mission information.
Snake, score 8,000 points.
Find the hidden item.
Grind 150 meters.
Collect four dog tags.
Destroy all three uninhabited probes.
Blow up...
square is flip okay thank you here we go oh yeah oh no it's
so awesome
oh my god we're grinding for no no no no we're oh i got
caught oh my god no no no and we're gonna grab just didn't
flip just kidding oh we did a kick flip Nice, Snake.
How many points do I have to...
Oh!
That was a big fall!
Are you okay, Snake?
Oh, I have to get on top of those.
Okay, hold on.
Oh, nice!
Good job, Snake!
Good job!
Nice!
Did we grind for 100...
How many meters was it?
How do I take this thing out?
Oh my god, it's shooting at me.
Kickflip!
Yes!
You should be more careful.
All you did was...
Snake, all you did was jump.
Oh my god!
How do I get the things up there?
Maybe here.
Nice!
A cipher.
How do I get the things up there, though?
And there's an item over here!
Oh, oh, snake, are you kidding me?
Oh my god.
Power slide.
How do I get it over there?
Is that the hidden item?
Wait, I think I can go down here too, though.
Can I?
Oh, sorry.
He's so thick, he bounced.
Oh, my God.
There's so much down here.
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
Wow!
Oh.
Ah!
Oh, good job, Snake.
He didn't crash.
He didn't crash and die this time.
Okay.
Thank you, Joshua.
I can't read it right now.
We have 24 seconds, you guys.
I don't think we're gonna make it.
Nice.
Good job, Snake.
We'll come back for that.
Oh.
What?
Oh my god.
What kind of mode was that?
A D, no way.
I didn't get a single man.
It's okay.
Don't scream while falling feels anticlimactic.
I like the way he kind of like flails his arms a little bit.
Did you guys hear that?
His little, oh, oh, oh.
Oh gosh.
Do I have to do it?
Wait, how fast do I have to go?
No way!
Body burial.
Okay.
Oh, it's still alive!
Uh-oh.
Nice.
50-50 grind.
Oh, it's still alive.
Oh, ow!
Oh god, we're bleeding!
Blue, British Whisp catching a stream for once, not a bot!
Thank you!
Sorry, I do plan on doing more, um, come on, Snake.
More, uh, EU-friendly streams.
Oh, that's a bird.
Okay, Snake, we need to get you up here.
Oh!
Ah!
Nice.
I should be more careful.
My bad.
Okay, let's go up here.
Here we go.
Nice!
Wow, this is actually huge.
Do a kick flip.
He listened so well.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
That should have been easy.
Three out of four?
Nice.
Where's the last one, I wonder?
How do I grab?
Oh, I stuck it!
I stuck it!
Oh!
Uh, let's go back downstairs, I guess.
Nice.
There's some stuff over here.
here.
Snake!
Ah!
Yeah, let's make the sound effect ourselves when we die,
right?
Okay, but how the heck?
Show us some tricks!
Come on!
Okay, we completed one mission!
We just gotta keep going!
Nose!
Okay, Snake.
Grab it!
Oh!
Oh my god!
Yo, yo, yo, you got so many.
Oh!
Ah!
Woo!
Oh!
Okay.
Come on.
8,000, please!
8,000!
Come on!
Kick flip!
Can I please, please, please!
No!
We were so close!
so close oh my gosh if only i had landed it
if only i had landed it neo thank you so much for the 20
captain thank you did you know that the engine that drives
this was made for the konami skateboarding game evolution
skateboarding which also has some big shell base levels as
well as castlevania i didn't know about that i didn't know
about the castlevania though actually Hidden grind.
Wait, we still haven't done the full grind?
Oh, dang.
Look at me go!
Oh, my God, get her!
Hey there, do that.
Could I get a totally tubular happy birthday on this raddest
anniversary of our nations and my birth?
Get your channel!
You have a pretty awesome birthday.
Happy birthday to you!
Happy April 30th.
The day of George Washington and of Gaia Channel.
Happy birthday.
To you.
Happy birthday!
I mean, have a radical birthday.
Bro.
Do you remember what day it is on April 30th?
Yeah, it's the day my dude Snake did a 1080 double ollie and
grind.
Dude is bodaciously radical and righteous.
Rose?
Oh my gosh.
Oh, I stuck that.
That was so crazy.
We got all four dog tags.
I want to blow up the plant.
Okay, that's going to be our goal right now.
It's figuring out how to blow up the plant.
I want to cause violence.
Oh, is it that over there?
No, hold on.
Oh, snake, turn around.
Oh, snake, you're doing awesome.
Oh, ah!
What a shame indeed.
Choose violence.
Let's go downstairs.
Let's see if we can find how to blow up.
Wait, can you stop for a second's sake so I can look around?
Maybe over there.
Oh, sorry.
Uh-oh.
Was that what I think it was?
Oh, wow!
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god, we made it!
Oh!
Um.
Whoa!
Oh god.
Oh, snake, get out of here, snake it out.
Snake.
There we go.
No, no, no, no.
Snake.
Okay, this way.
Never mind.
Okay.
50 50 50 oh
I see it's a total of 150 okay okay I don't know why I
thought I had done it oh my god huh snake you have to you
have to jump up high enough duckie thank you ghost tack you
the shredder oh gosh no no we need that come Come on!
Snake!
I wonder if there's a way to get more time.
There's not much point being here if you don't do any trick.
Shut up!
Narrator!
Okay, Snake.
Jump.
Don't do it!
Just trying to turn around.
I'm just... There we go.
Check the other side.
Like, yeah, let's try this side.
Hua!
Oh wait, we need this!
Wait.
Oh, you're... I think we need this part.
Okay, hold on.
Oh, hold on.
Snake.
Turn around.
Turn around, Snake.
Snake.
Ouch.
Oh my god!
Looking good, he said.
Oh!
Interesting.
dead anyway.
Okay, so once we get that, how do I still have a D?
Okay, then we have to go get the other ones.
Looking good.
I'm a disaster.
Yeah, this is a disaster.
Look at that.
That's so sick.
Look at him go.
Don't look at that.
Don't look at that part.
Let's try and replay.
I wonder.
You're killing it, dude.
Go!
Uh-oh, I don't think I killed him.
I don't think I killed him.
Oh,
it shows the video of what I did.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Oh my god.
Oh, I made it.
How did I make it?
Oh!
Snake, don't do it.
Okay, Snake, I need you to just turn around, buddy.
Very slowly.
There you go.
Okay.
Yeah!
No, please.
Snake, turn around.
We need some.
Oh, wait.
Let's go to this one real quick.
Whoa!
Oh!
We made it, we made it, we made it, we made it.
Okay, there we go, there we go.
Where are those?
Oh, snake.
Oh, my God.
He gets a little, he gets a little out of control, you know?
Okay.
Nice.
Yeah.
Oh, my God.
Guys, I'm killing it.
Nice.
Oh.
Almost had it.
I think it's on this side.
Let's go and destroy our side-out gear.
Wow!
Okay, now where the other one is, I don't know.
Uh, wait, now that's a door.
Keep going.
Upstairs maybe?
You think it's upstairs maybe?
Is this David Hater VAing?
I wish.
Shut up!
I'm going!
Oh, there it is.
He
dead?
Wait.
Wait!
Where is that?
Oh, got a dog tag.
Oh, oh, ouch.
Ouch, ouch.
Come on, Snake.
Get it back up.
Oh, my God.
No, no, don't get me again.
Mission completed.
Okay, let's do a little celebratory grab or that, whatever
the hell that was.
Oh my God, are you okay, Snake?
He's fine, he's fine.
I wonder if the hidden is like, get all the birds or
something, you know, something crazy like that.
Nice!
Oh!
We almost had it.
Still a D!
This makes me want to see you play the original Tony Hawk's
game and Tony Hawk's Underground.
You should be more careful.
That's so awesome!
That sound is so great.
Wait, hold on, I'm gonna see it next.
If we do replay, let's see.
Oh, yeah, you're right.
Slow.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, my God.
Wow.
How do I go fast?
Oh.
Wait, no, no, no, back, back, back, back.
I went.
Yeah!
And then...
Slow...
Oh, no, snake.
And then I stood there trying to turn around.
Frame advance.
Oh wow, we could get like frame perfect shots.
Yeah!
I think he's a pro.
It's okay, he lived.
It's okay.
It's me trying to do the setup.
It's killing me.
L1 is slow, right?
It doesn't feel very slow.
Yeah!
Oh my gosh, we went crazy there.
Oh, God.
Yeah!
Oh, and then I fell off.
That's okay.
Surprise, they didn't include Fat Man on his rollerblades
for this.
Right!
It would have been perfect.
Oh, I'm crying.
I'm crying from laughing so much.
It only has been a half hour.
This game is kind of cruel, though.
They give you... Oh, okay.
Oh, oh, I clicked restart.
Oh, no.
They only give you like so few times, so few minutes.
Thank you, diving.
Could you perhaps, my chance be untubular?
Absolutely not.
I am the most tubular.
Ghost man you'll ever meet.
There's one thing.
You'll find it hard to believe.
I saw a man grinding on a skateboard on the connecting half
pipe to Shell 2.
I've seen someone use that box strip before.
We'll lay a trap on Shell 2.
Connecting half pipe.
There he goes.
Okay, retry.
How many, how much time do we have?
Three minutes?
Bodifarion.
Oh, no snake.
Jump.
Nose grab.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no.
Dang it.
We got it though.
Nice.
How do we get the ones up there?
What?
I want... Oh, sorry, snake.
I also want the stuff back there.
Okay.
Go, snake.
No, go.
Hoorah!
Impossible!
We make the impossible possible.
I have to, I have a feeling that the...
That the birds have something to do with the hidden one.
Oh, nice.
Nice.
Not today.
Cipher!
Ouch!
Why are you still shooting me?
This is good, isn't it?
Can you imagine what big boss would think?
Oh yeah, let's go.
Let's go blow up.
Dead, dead, dead, dead, dead, dead, dead, dead.
Okay.
Oh, nicer!
Oh, snake, snake, jump.
There we go.
Yeah.
Yeah!
Big boss would be like, that's my son.
Oh, no!
I was not a lion.
It's okay.
50-50 grunt!
This remix is awesome.
Oh, what the- what's going on?
My son.
Oh, no!
Stay here!
Nose grind.
Grind mission completed!
Here's the true mission.
The true challenge.
Ah!
Ugh.
We only have 30 seconds, Snake.
We gotta get...
We gotta get Destroying.
I'm trying!
I'm trying, sir!
Please.
Snake!
Yes, yes, yes.
Nice!
Okay, okay, okay.
Let's go get the first one.
Come on, Snake.
Come on, we got this.
Right here, right here, right here, right here.
Right here!
Don't try too hard.
Oh, oh, oh no, we don't have the time!
Go, Snake, go!
I don't think we're gonna make it.
Oh, we're not gonna make it.
Ugh.
Don't try too hard.
We only got one in the end.
Actually, it says there's four.
It says there's four.
Four ciphers, but...
But I only saw three.
We gotta go find the last one.
Retry.
Let's go try it.
Let's go find the last one.
Hmm.
A board to surpass Metal Gear.
We didn't take him out, but that's...
Okay.
This way.
Oh my god.
How am I supposed to do this?
No way.
Wait, do I go, like, from up here?
Ooh, we made it.
We lived.
Okay.
Okay,
hold on.
We need some...
Oh, we need some air.
We need some air.
We need some...
Here we go.
Okay, from here, from here.
And jump!
Snake, why don't you jump?
Why don't you jump, Snake?
Why?
There's not much point being here that don't do any tricks.
Jump!
I think it's jump and release.
the release okay like I think it's okay like this jump okay
okay I get it now I get it now okay so it's you hold I get
it I get it I get it here we go come on snake okay now
that's what am I supposed to do there wait do I Can I grind
and jump at the same time?
It's like that in Tony Hawk, too.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
Jump off.
Oh, wait.
Oh, so close.
You're so close.
Good jump.
No, how am I supposed to jump?
Oh, my gosh.
We're going to get this.
This is what we'll practice.
Okay, here we go.
I'm holding... I'm holding...
Jump!
Grind on the handrail instead.
Hmm.
There's no way I should keep getting a D.
Okay, let's go back to that spot.
Let's go back to that spot.
Jump.
Yeah.
Okay.
Oop!
I pressed the wrong line.
Okay,
okay, okay.
I think I get the timing.
Oh my god.
Alright, here we go.
Turn around.
Go.
This is so tricky.
It's okay.
Snake, you got this.
You got this, buddy.
Fine, what it's doing!
Hold on.
Okay, hold on.
Too early might be better than too late.
Hold on.
If I'm grinding, grind, grind, grind on there.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
I'm shredding.
We got this!
Dude!
I was a little off on my calculations.
We have a whole minute to learn this.
Oh!
This guy is getting on my nerves.
How is it so funny every time?
It's the way he flails his arm, you know?
Alright, here we go, here we go.
Why?
When I'm off, sometimes he catches it.
Other times, he doesn't catch it.
Okay.
There we go.
Please show us some tricks.
Please do something.
Okay.
Down.
Ah!
What?
Okay, you guys?
I...
I... I was holding X the whole time!
Okay, okay.
Oh, look!
Okay, that one I was not holding X.
But did you release X?
No, I did!
You can't see my hat!
Actually, you can see my hands.
But my hands are shredding right now.
I'm focused on my own grind, okay?
Okay.
Are you playing through OBS?
Oopsie!
Ta-ching!
I basically, that was like a hoop though.
Come on.
How do you land that?
Come on, Snake.
All you did was jump!
Oh my god.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Bomb rush cyberpunk.
I don't
even see what it was!
What was the hidden?
Where's the...
I'm trapped here.
Oh.
I'm trapped here, you guys.
Uh-oh.
No snake.
Turn around.
No.
That's a disappointment.
What was the thing on it?
Okay, here we go.
Oh, come on Snake.
We need you to catch some...
I did not press X soon enough, that was mean.
It's all mean.
It's okay though, we got it one time, we can get it again.
This is it.
What?!
I held X, you game.
You game, I held X.
Fifty-fifth.
Two!
No, please.
Please, I held X and I let go.
This is so messed up.
This is so messed up, Stank.
Okay, come on.
Why not grind on the rails outside?
Instead of jumping?
Because you have to hear...
Because they cut off.
You have to do it.
Oh, unless you mean like...
Okay, I think I...
So like controlling it to go to the...
Okay.
I think I know what you mean.
I think I know...
Hold on, let me see.
I think...
I think I get what you're saying.
I think I'm catching what you're putting down.
I think I'm understanding the gravity of the situation.
Oh god.
I think I got it.
I think I know what you mean.
I'm gonna try it.
No guarantee you so.
Like so here And then oh I won't let it.
Unless it's like pitch perfect.
I don't know about that one.
Yeah, I don't...
What's over here too?
Alright, snake!
But slowly, slowly, slowly, snake, slowly.
Don't, you don't want to die here.
Snake, snake.
Looking good!
Why can't I, why can't I grab it?
What?
Um...
Okay, I think it's, uh, bugged maybe.
Nice.
Oh.
Ah!
We got this guy.
Oh!
Do I have a health?
I wonder.
Oh, we almost made it.
No, no, Snake!
Snake, don't die!
Phantom coin.
Okay.
Oh!
Almost.
No!
I don't think it read the input.
Happy Big Shell Day!
Happy!
Whoa!
Big Shell Day, everybody!
Yeah!
Whoa!
Yes!
A deal!
After all of that, still, we get the big D.
It's a hind D.
A hind D.
Let's check out Ryden's.
End game.
That was a good run, though.
Good run, everybody.
Wait.
Oh, wait.
Oh, I just realized my bad.
I thought...
I don't know what I thought.
Sorry, my...
My place, PS2, is going kind of crazy.
Minty is ready for the X games.
2!
Hope you're having a totally gnarly April 30th and enjoying
the FGS skateboarding.
The full game is playable Grelukovic soldiers, Simon
Belmont, Frogger the Frog, and boss battles against enemies
like Dracula.
Plus it's fun having snakes skate in Tokyo.
Yeah!
Oh my gosh!
Split stream Sam.
Looking pretty rad, boss.
Thanks.
is this this is how george washington always wanted us to
commemorate today don't you agree this is actually how we
crossed the delaware river i didn't know if you knew that i
didn't i didn't know that that guy mr washington i hope
you're watching this is what you fought for this is what
makes us free the right to skate wherever we please oh it
would have been so cool I had blown up the...
Okay, let's try it.
I wonder if there's a blow-up one for Ryzen 2.
So this is Route B.
I wonder...
So I guess it's different.
Two!
Prognosticatura.
Mint has to nerf herself through OBS because she would be
too good.
I finally figured out how to do it, though.
Operate the crane.
Collect four rations.
Wait, is there less stuff for Ryzen?
than there is for snake where am I crazy 8,000 points Ryan
150 look at his sir what are you doing to the skateboard huh
yeah oh yeah there's no dog tags yeah yeah hands on the sir
Raiden?
Oh, he's serving.
Look at him.
Rations instead of dog tags.
Go!
I see a ration right over here.
Oh, I keep...
Whoa, look at there's a whole place here for us to grind.
Tailslide.
There it is.
Oh, oh, whoa, whoa.
Oh, dang it.
I don't think I destroyed it, though.
Ow!
Oh, God, right in your head.
Are you okay?
Oh, you almost had it.
It's time for Jack to let it kick.
You guys like that?
Err.
Riden, Riden.
Rules of Skater.
Thank you for the Hakusuma.
Oh my god, please.
Um, we'll just ignore that for now, okay?
Just kidding.
Justice has been served.
Nice.
It's okay.
We at least took him out.
Nice!
Doctor, turn off my skate inhibitors.
It's time for Jack.
Let her rip.
Come on, birds.
Oh, it almost had that skating here.
I realized.
Nice.
Almost had the body variable, but we at least killed the
thing.
Keep going, keep going.
Oh, so close.
So close.
Oh, I thought I was about to die.
Yeah!
That's the way, baby.
How do I destroy?
We'd be down.
Oh.
Whoa, we made that.
No, no.
I like destroying the boxes too.
Oh, yo!
We did that guy.
This is the crane, obviously.
Hmm.
We gotta figure out.
Let's see here.
Retry, retry, retry.
Go!
Let's do this first.
50, 50, 50.
Oh, I can never make it.
Oh my god.
Come on, come on, Ryden.
Nice!
I can never get the body barrier.
What?
Was it,
Was it, you know, It's like, It's like, it's like, it's
like, it's like,
Of course they wanted to say kawaii instead of kawaii, you
know what I'm saying?
Oh no!
Impossible!
Even though I didn't get it.
Nice.
Wait, is the hidden spot in the same place?
No way.
That was sweet!
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, jojo, jojo, jojo,
jojo, jojo.
Oh, dang it.
Nice.
Took that guy out.
I'm starting to get sweaty.
I'm shredding too much, dude.
I'm just...
Okay, here we go.
Oh no, I almost had it!
I forgot.
Okay.
It's not a disappointment.
My mom says...
I'm not a disappointment.
Okay, hold on.
Oh no, I jumped too early.
I jumped too early.
Denver!
Welcome.
To...
Membo!
Ship!
We got this.
Please!
Please, I don't have much time!
Please, game!
No, please, Watashi!
Riden!
Stop going through, okay.
Please, Watashi, make it!
Ha!
Not the hidden.
Huh?
That wasn't the hidden?
Oh.
baited for real okay let's try and find the way to activate
the crane I also want to find I only know where two rations
are nice you're so radical made man be to work thank you
thanks I know I like I like, no I am.
Getting some sick air.
Is this even possible?
I don't know, let's go upstairs.
Oh, come on.
Ryden, you just, you have to push.
Oh, is this it?
Oh!
There's the hidden!
One out of, oh.
That's a disappointment.
Nice.
Keep it going.
It's right there, isn't it?
Oh,
I have to go downstairs and do it.
Okay, erg.
Oh, there's the other ration.
Oh, we made it!
Let's go.
Wait, what does Circle do again?
I can't remember what the difference between Circle and...
Square.
One of them's grab.
One of them's something.
How do you use your special?
I have no idea.
Circle is grab.
Circle is grab tricks.
Okay, okay, okay.
I tried maybe like grabbing the side of it.
It didn't really work.
No, I didn't know.
Oh, actually that works.
what is this what happened on april 30th uh you know it you
know it
oh and that's how we get the hidden
oh come on get out of here just leave oh just go just go all
right just go just go I want to get more than a D.
I want to get...
A C!
Oh, no.
Oh, so close.
No, ration, please.
I want to get a C.
Yes!
That might be it.
That might be C.
That might be a C, you guys.
Can we get any more?
Whoa!
Are you kidding me?
Are you like...
Squidding me right now?
Is it just D or...
D or no D?
You know?
You have to get the D or else...
or else is a C in my heart thanks f no it's a D don't make
it any lower
because I'm not doing enough side tricks oh sorry sick
tricks actually though
riding oh riding we gotta grind We get a score.
What's the crash?
Wait, what is...
Oh, the probes.
Look at the membership!
Thank you!
Score's too low.
So maybe it doesn't have anything to do with the missions.
Maybe it's all...
Maybe it's more to do with the...
There it is.
our actual score.
What if I just grind the whole time?
There we go.
Nice.
Special R1.
Can get you a lot of points.
Oh, R1 is our special.
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
Okay.
Also, I keep forgetting about this.
We can flip in the air.
Keep forgetting.
Smooth!
So we have to go upstairs first, right?
So far so good.
Ish.
Come on, Ryden.
Oh, I keep forgetting about L2 and R2.
Oops, we did something there.
Oh, oh no!
Ryden!
Ryden, go back, go back, go back.
Minty's a real skater, not a poser, obviously.
Oh, see?
Only a real skater would have landed that.
Okay, let's go back downstairs.
Go right in.
Right in.
Wait, turn around.
Oh, wait.
Actually, yeah, I wanted to do that.
Maybe I'm not, like, hitting enough of the...
Or landing enough.
Nice.
I destroy the things, but I don't land the trick, you know?
Come on.
Let's go.
And...
Nice.
Why does this game even have skateboarding?
Why wouldn't it?
Because MGS2 is the greatest of all time!
I'm grinding up the stairs.
grinding up the steps.
Go, go, go.
Come on, Ryzen.
Oh my god, please.
Oh my god.
That was close.
Okay.
Now we gotta get this ration.
Wait.
Does L2...
Maybe L2 and R2 don't do anything.
I'm trying!
Oh my god, wait, no, please.
Oh.
Didn't I say though?
What was the jump button again?
It's X.
That was, um...
That was...
You guys!
We did it!
We got the C!
I actually feel like I was doing pretty well until the end
there.
if i had collected if i had gotten that and then the score
oh my gosh random well-being checkup how have you been big
mint here's 50 do is get yourself some bread mate maybe some
by me too thank you i'm good thank you so much i mean i'm
totally tubular i just gotta see and you know what see means
degree see means degree yeah
Seas get degrees.
That's the saying.
Seas be degrees Celsius.
Oh man.
Absolutely.
Sea means cool.
I like the blowing.
I actually think the snake's map was harder.
I think it was more difficult.
But maybe that means we can actually um complete all the
missions on this one who knows oh no no come on come on
riding get it together buddy so close
oh see see see oh wait I did go the right way I thought it
was going wrong Okay, that's fine too.
Raiden, please.
Raiden!
Raiden.
So take care of the terrorists.
You must grind.
Oh damn.
We didn't.
He's gonna...
Yeah!
All according to plan, obviously.
Nice!
Oh no!
I was so close.
Just a deal.
You know what?
We got the money.
We got the cash money.
It's fine.
Let's get out of here.
Let's go blow it.
Let's not blow it.
Let's go do a crane.
Sick Kekaku, bro.
Kickflip!
Give us some extra points while we're...
Oh!
Oh, come on, Rydid.
Come on, Rydid, Rydid.
Okay, you know what?
This works too.
We gotta get the, we gotta get our grind on.
We gotta get our grind on.
Ouch.
I missed that a little bit.
No, that is not a solid snake.
That's sick snake.
Yeah!
Looks like out of seven Uniques.
What?
Okay, all right, here we go.
Did we land it, though?
Did we land it?
Did we land the impossible?
That's so close!
Ryden, Ryden, please turn around.
Ryden, I can't see you.
Okay.
They don't call it the impossible for nothing.
It's mostly for him.
It's for his ego, you know.
it the impossible but it's like the easiest trick ever
wouldn't that just make him feel really bad april 30th my
dudes april 30th george washington oh take it oh there's not
much point being here if you don't do any tricks um this one
was not my best run i'll be honest
What an end.
Truly.
Lollilule.
It's a Lollilule.
They're trying to stop me, the Lollilule.
Oh, damn.
That was so close.
Please, Bryden.
Get a bit of...
Disaster.
That's me.
That's what they call me at the club!
Disaster.
Lallelu.
What's up here?
I haven't been here.
Oh.
I did not see that hole.
Ha!
Oh, dang it.
Uh-oh.
We're in trouble.
Ah!
Don't shoot!
Oh!
What club?
Nice.
Oh, so close.
I also want to get these up here.
Oh my god, that was so sick.
He was shooting at me and I was...
Yeah!
He was shooting at me, but I was too busy Being awesome!
Yeah, the club, obviously.
Oh, oh, oh, please, riding.
Let's go upstairs.
Take the stairs now, riding.
Here we go!
I take- I phased into the box.
I'm gonna take Cypher down with a skateboard.
Yeah.
Yeah, I do.
Cypher's got nothing on me.
well this those ciphers and and this cipher wait those wait
cipher and these ciphers
okay that's all right riding so pick it up pick it up no no
wrong way there we go up the stairs one of my mortal enemies
that i can't ever The stairs.
Weren't you about those stairs, bro?
Yeah!
Oh.
Oh, sorry, Ryden.
Why can't I get this?
But it's so hard for me to get this ration.
Oh my god.
What?
Why'd you stop, Ryden?
Why'd you stop?
Uh...
In the end...
Everything is bad.
I did one, I just did it!
Come on, come on.
Ration!
We didn't get the grind either.
I think getting the grind is like...
Going...
There and back.
know what i mean okay like this nice
oh why did you why did you fall
so close that's okay though now we go around this way we
waste all this time and we hook we're going so slow oh my
god right and don't do it don't write it
We gotta grind everything we see.
Like we're a bunny or something.
Badass.
Where's all the bird poop?
That's a good question.
I took care of those birds.
Nice.
Oh, for some reason I keep thinking I gotta go back here.
But I don't.
Not yet.
Not here yet.
Like you're a what?
What do you mean?
Oh, let's just pretend we don't see what.
I didn't want those points.
Anyway!
Ryden, I need you to...
I need you to...
You know, my money's on you.
Ryden, Ryden, my money's on you.
I need you to...
Ryden, I'm gonna go broke.
Ryden, don't you care about me?
Oh, we got the grind at least.
Ryden.
Lock in, Ryden.
You know what?
Let's just do this part.
Oh, I don't think we're gonna make it!
I don't think we're gonna make it!
I miss them in the game would just tell you you're bad.
Ryden, that's a disappointment.
Stop making me so sad!
Oh, Ryden!
Ryden!
You're making Mike sad.
Oh, sorry, I just realized.
I'm, I'm, I'm, my, my, my contacts.
Okay, here we go.
I hate this guy, I think.
That's got to hurt.
Okay.
Oh my gosh, maybe.
No!
How do I get that one up there?
Ugh!
C though, we got the C.
We got the C.
If I had just gotten that at the last second, maybe it would
have been a B.
Jump?
I've tried.
Hold on, you know what?
We're going to go practice that one right now.
We're going to go straight to it and practice.
This way.
This way, this way.
and
if i jump well that obviously didn't work hold x and release
at the edge of the ramp no need to hold forward okay
eyes are eyes are my man eyes are my man
that was all you buddy Oh, oh, oh, there we go.
Nice, so.
Oh, I could not see.
All right.
Let's, um, oh.
Oh my god, please.
Oh.
We wasted a little bit of time, but it's okay.
Let's just feed.
you cypher's.
Ooh!
That hurt over here.
Oh, is that right in?
Right in.
All we did was...
All we did was turn around.
All we did was turn around, man.
Oh.
Wait, which one's kickflip?
Wait.
Oh, wait.
Kickflip!
It's a kick, and then it's a flip.
Oh, wait.
Oh, right in.
Right in.
Oh,
gee, is this real?
You bet your butt it's real.
Went through our soak.
Whoa, what was that?
Come on.
Oh, right.
Let's go, right in.
What's stock one mean?
Oh, didn't someone say...
I can do like a special trick or something.
Does that mean my special is stocked up?
Huh.
Oh.
Wait.
That's my special meter.
R1!
Does nothing!
I got another stock!
But how do I use it?
Hmm.
Nice.
How do I use it?
Hmm.
Oh, I was gonna say, wait, I got the collection.
No, we didn't at the beginning.
Okay, I think this time, for real, we can get the
collection.
If we can get a B for...
Biden, ball, bake, burn, then I think we'll be good.
Bows.
Huh!
Oh,
dang it.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh, no.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, yippee!
B for blocks.
B for...
BJ!
Wait, no, no, no, never mind.
I was thinking D for DJ, but...
No!
I didn't mean that!
You guys know PD for DJ, right?
Whoa!
Okay, I think I'm normal again.
Yes.
No.
You don't seem to have enough guts to 20- Yes, sir.
No, sir.
Oh, it's Ryden, please.
We only have a minute, Ryden.
There we go.
Yes, sir.
No, sir.
I cannot stop saying that.
I think there's something wrong with my brain.
I can't just stop saying, Yes, sir.
No, sir.
Yes, sir.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, no!
Actually, this is okay.
To thank you!
Yeah!
Oh, my God.
Wait, you guys.
I just need the score.
No, no, no, no, please!
Ryden, Ryden, don't do this to me!
Oh, so close!
Oh my gosh!
No, not B for BJ!
Not B!
But we got the B!
Wee, wee, wee, wee!
We got the B.
Oh, you're making progress.
Yeah, baby.
Yes, sir.
It takes a well-balanced individual to grind the rails.
B for ghost booze.
Boo, boo, boo.
Yeah, boo, boo.
Oh, I'm sweating so much.
Do you guys mind if I go get some more water?
Here, you can watch the replay while I go get more water.
I'll be right back.
Here, I'll even get rid of this.
BRB.
Wait a second.
I just joined the stream for the BJ.
Wait, no!
Wait, I might need to go change.
No!
I'm my dress all wrinkly.
Oh.
I think I've sat weird and it's all rink right here.
Oh no.
Wait, I'm gonna go change.
I'll be right back.
Okay, again.
BRV part two.
So sorry.
Hold on.
I'm gonna restart it for those who missed it.
Restart.
There we go.
All right, BRV.
I have T-minus three minutes.
Into my shirt.
Okay.
I'm so sorry, you guys, I'm so sorry.
Okay, okay, okay.
Exit.
Alright.
I changed into my Hungry for Snake t-shirt.
I realized I don't have any MGS 2 t-shirts.
I have only MGS 3.
Well, I have MGS 4, MGS 3, Peace Walker.
I didn't buy the one from Uniqlo because I didn't like it.
The blue on it is so blue.
It's so blue.
Like it's way too blue.
I'll never wear it.
I do have one that says solidus on it.
Maybe I should have worn that instead.
Oh the fat man!
My laugh at growing.
Ah, yeah.
Alright, guys.
I...
Today's stream is actually going to be pretty short.
So...
Um...
How did you know I had that t-shirt?
Actually, it's not a t-shirt.
But, you know.
How did you know I had a shirt that said laugh and grow bad?
Is it because I love Fat Man so much, you knew?
Um, Min, do you know what day it is today?
April 30th?
It's Shredding Day!
Every MGS fan has it.
Oh, okay, okay.
But, I believe this is the round where we'll get an A for
that ass.
Yeah!
Let's go.
Let's grind.
all the way to dinner baby oh ouch uh that was not what I
expected um hey uh wait wait wait why are you facing this
way okay we're close we're close April April 30th so right
why didn't I think of that you should be the streamer not me
oh Ew.
Oh, ew, the camera.
That's okay.
This should be you on this live stream.
Not me!
Nice.
Why do you not land the kickflips right in?
You're killing me.
You're tearing me apart, right in.
That was so wet.
Ryden.
Hold on, I'm coming back over here to get...
Oh, never mind.
You know what?
Screw it.
Send in Grey Fox.
It's like when you play as Grey Fox in VR missions.
I did!
Ryden's bloody skin, Mark.
What do you mean by that?
Oh, my gosh.
I don't think this is the run, you guys.
Um, uh-oh.
Uh-oh.
I don't know if this is the run, but we'll try.
Oh, wrong way.
Oh my gosh.
We'll try.
Oh.
Okay.
Come on.
Oh, whoa, whoa.
All right, we'll go back up the stairs.
I held on, but it...
Uh...
Well, we haven't even gotten that one.
Yo, this is not the run at all.
That's okay.
Good job, Ryden.
Nice.
Turn around, Ryden.
Ouch, ouch.
That's okay!
That we didn't make it.
That's okay.
We didn't get the grind either.
Yeah, we're getting consistencies though.
Not so bad.
Okay, here we go.
How
do I use my special?
Oh, if only I hadn't crashed, we would have made that.
Ooh, this one's fancy.
Nice.
Okay.
There we go.
Speed run, speed run, speed run.
Nice.
Okay.
Kick flip.
Kick flip, my beloved.
Nice.
Oh, not nice.
You still need to grind though.
Come on, ride it, ride it, ride it!
I know.
I'm trying, I'm trying.
I'm trying.
Mr. please.
okay when we go back down we'll get that probably
jump oh okay turn around jump yeah okay
Let's go get these over here.
I still have to make like a lot of points though.
Tailslide!
Oh!
Okay, that kid got us a lot.
Nice.
Let's just do it again.
Yes!
Oh, that works, that works, that works, that works.
Oh no, oh no, no, no.
Please.
Oh,
we did it!
Let's go!
Oh my god!
April 30th!
Yeah!
Oh my gosh!
You guys, it is time to do the final part of April 30th.
While we watch...
My awesome run.
While we watch my awesome run, punch solidus no not yet I
love that guy hold on a second here we go
okay well guys thank you very much for joining me for this
super awesome super cool super sick time today I hope that
you had an awesome April 30th And remember that the Patriots
will never win.
It was time to watch King Kong.
No, it's time for our final part.
Actually, I'm gonna restart this.
Restart, there we go.
Okay, I will sing to you a song.
I stare at the stars and the sky up above And think, what am
I made of?
Am I full of sorrow?
Am I hurt?
pain or am I filled with love I walk by myself on the
streets below and as every child I know do you think
tomorrow I'll nail that kickflip which one wait which which
trick will go I can't say goodbye to yesterday my friend I
keep holding on till the end out of the darkness there is no
other away than the light leading to yesterday.
It's there that I'll find inner peace, not war, and dreams
that I let slip away.
Joan, please.
I'm the ration I'm looking for Way back in yesterday I
forgot
my saxophone This is cinnamon
Why can't each of us in the world ever see the best things
in life are free little sounds of laughter a warm hug a
smile a kickflip from you to me I fall to my knees I cry and
I cry Why couldn't I just fly?
On my skateboard Help me ever after Please stay for a while
Make time, refuse to fly I can't say goodbye to yesterday my
friend because I know how good it has been facing forever
here I stand come what made the old and the new yesterday
it's there that I'll find inner peace, not war and boards
that I let slip away I will find the joyfulness I'm looking
for today April 38
Oh, here it comes.
Come on.
Wow.
This is a trumpet.
This is not a saxophone.
The sax tease.
.
Thank you guys again.
That's a trombone?
Oh.
That's a trombone, but we don't have a...
Hold on, I'm going to skate with him.
I'm going to skate with him.
Oh.
Yeah!
Whoa!
Here I go!
Yeah!
Oh, here!
Ooh!
Here we go, here we go.
Oh, I tried.
Kick flip!
Keep going!
Keep going, riding!
Yes!
Yeah!
Da da da da da I can't say goodbye to yesterday My friend Oh
We're okay, we're okay Da da da da da da Wow!
uh that's it that's the stream thank you guys again i hope
you had fun um happy april 30th from me to you and um so
gnarly thanks for the stream thank you guys i'll see you
guys uh tomorrow actually i will be collabing with Geary on
her channel um I don't I actually I think I can stream
tomorrow I don't know I think I'll stream tomorrow probably
gonna tell you now you are not beating the cute allegation
what is that what do you mean I'm not cool I mean cute I'm
cool whoa here we go yeah
Oh, never mind.
I was going to take that, but I didn't.
Okay.
130th Happy Metal Gear Day.
Again, I'll probably stream tomorrow.
I don't know what yet.
I'll put up a waiting room tomorrow morning, probably, after
the giddy collab.
Yeah!
Otsuminto!
Thank you everybody!
I know it's silly but the stream has been the coolest thing
and the song just wow.
Thank you so much!
Thanks Venkiro!
Otsuminto!
Bara-tuminto!
Isn't it so awesome we also got the A?
I'll try and get an A on Snake's map too.
But I think I'm way better now than I was before.
I think we could do it.
Also oh my gosh you guys!
so close to 200k.
I had to think of something to do for 200k.
Uh-oh.
Yes.
Almost.
4k.
4k left.
Wait.
Oh, it doesn't say...
What does it say, actually?
I don't know what this is.
I don't know if it says anything like that.
Yeah, 4k left.
Oh my gosh.
200k calories.
Eat 200k calories.
Got it.
I'm going to eat 200k calories.
Perfect.
No elation 200 times.
You would want that, wouldn't you?
Oh, dookie, bro.
I think of something.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you for subscribing, big friend.
Thanks for being me.
Okie dokie.
See ya.
See ya, see ya bye.
How, uh, y'all, y'all stay safe out there.
Y'all, y'all be good out there.
Uh, bye-bye now.
Bye-bye.
Durant's karaoke to 200k.
When?
Oh, I don't know, I don't know.
I mean, I have karaoke on Saturday, but, um, I know.
I, I'm trying to rest my throat a little bit, so.
But bye-bye now.
Bye-bye.
We'll see.
Uh, I don't know about karaoke.
Maybe something else.
Bye-bye now.
Bye-bye.
Bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye